[Music]
get ready ran fans because Miranda
Lambert is back with new music and it
all arrives before the end of 2019
that's right the Texas native 7,000 men
first since for 2016 double platinum
records the weight of these wings will
arrive on November 1st and whether
you're into the feel-good tracks or her
classic rocker sound there's something
for everyone now back in August the
singer revealed the album title wildcard
along with the gorgeous coverage and
speaking to Rolling Stone country in
June Lambert shared some details on the
new record saying quote there were some
fun moments on the weight of these wings
but that whole portion of my life and
art was not the funnest time with this
one I just wanted to cut loose a little
bit and has she ever cut loose the
singer has been dropping songs all
summer including the album's lead single
it all comes out in the wash which
debuted at number 18 on Billboard's
Country airplay chart marking her second
highest debut since vice in 2016 Lambert
says the song is a fun reminder that
hard times eventually pass and she sure
does prove that as she enjoys a
fun-filled day of off-roading and
mudding in the new music video
on the same day she released it all
comes out in the wash
we ran to surprise fans with another
song titled locomotive which brings us
back to where punk rock sound and we are
loving it take a listen
[Music]
now one major change on the album is her
switch from longtime producer Frank
Liddell to Jay Joyce who is the go-to
collaborator for some of country's
biggest stars including Eric Church and
Carrie Underwood so it's safe to say
this change will work out just fine for
Miranda and she continues to shake off
the heaviness from the weight of these
wings with another upbeat rockers song
titles mess with my head
[Music]
just when he thought she was done
dropping songs
Miranda released a reflective mid-tempo
ballad titled Bluebird which offers a
slightly different feel than the other
rock oriented tracks and the album
actually takes its title from a lyric in
the song
[Music]
and all the stars go
you keep the little bird
as for collaborations on the record
Lambert teams up with Maren Morris for
the ultimate girl anthem way too pretty
for prison about a girl looking for a
revenge against her cheatin partner yep
these two kill this
and help you kill them
[Music]
and for her most recent release Miranda
sings about her Airstream trailer while
paying tribute to her late grandmother
in pretty bitchin rollin down the road
you ought to see the pretty Wow Walton
I bet on the floor no lock on the door
help it
pretty bitchin
all six singles will join 14 others as
Miranda revealed the complete tracklist
on social media and it's safe to say all
these teasers have made us even more
excited for the arrival of wildcards and
she'll be taking these songs on the road
for her roadside bar's and pink guitars
tour which carries out through the fall
and for recently announced wild-card
tour which kicks off in 2020 so what do
you think of Miranda's new album so far
what tracks are you excited to hear let
us know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe to ET Canada's p2
page
[Music]